every year nature quietly takes us
through a moral lesson that has much to
teach us about how we might relate to
certain of the more dispiriting and
despair-inducing moments in our own
development
beginning in mid-october in the northern
hemisphere the temperature drops the
nights draw in the earth turns cold and
hard fog lies low over the land and rain
drives hard across the austere comatose
grey-brown landscape
there is nothing immediate we can hope
for
now we have nothing to do but wait with
resigned patients until something better
shows up
far more than we can generally accept
our minds too have cycles
we cannot be permanently fruitful or
creative excited or open
there are necessary times of
retrenchment when whatever we might
desire there seems no alternative but to
stop
we can no longer be productive
we lose direction and inspiration
we are immovably numb and sterile
it can be easy to panic
why should such a paralyzed and detached
mood have descended on our formerly
lively minds
where have all our ideas and hopes gone
what has happened to our previous
animation and gladness
we should at such times take reassurance
from the late november landscape
certainly things are lifeless cold and
in suspension but this is not the end of
the story
the earth is like this not as a
destination but as a phase
the deadness is a prelude to new life
the fallow period is a guarantor of
second days to come
all living organisms need to recharge
themselves
old leaves have to give way
tired limbs must rest the dance and
ferment could not go on
it may look as if nothing at all is
happening as though this is a trance
without purpose
yet deep underground at this very moment
nutrients are being gathered the
groundwork for future ebullience and
dynamism is being laid down
another summer is very slowly collecting
its strength as nature seeks to tell us
we cannot permanently be in flower
we need moments of repose and confusion
there is nothing to fear things will
re-emerge
we should make our peace with our own
mid-winters
and lean on nature's wise accommodation
to strengthen us in our pursuit of
serenity and patience
for more from the school of life
you can subscribe to our channel and
take a look at our range of products on
our website
you